I'm realizing more and more about why I am
the way I am from when I was really little and I could hear my mom and dad
Arguing like about money or something
I can't talk to them about that because all they want to talk about is how tender the chicken is
That's the idea of a deep chat
You know every single time we're eating someone who variably comes out of a comment about the tenderness of the meat
Mom was depressed and I
never really focused on that, but it's
Clear that she was and I think that man if I had a problem that it was always a problem too much
I know it dad were arguing all the time, which obviously doesn't help things
I think that's why I have these issues with
Confidence and this whole like background of shame all the time and probably why I do this
OCD type stuff and explains drinking and explains drugs like
Huh, chicken's very tender -- extremely tender
We're not talking about something other than the food
'Cause I come here every Sunday and we eat and all we talk about is the food
I've been reading this a lot and I think it explains
a lot about why things keep going wrong why I can't
Start a new relationship why works all over the place?
It's because I haven't received that bedrock of human love that everyone needs. Like -- Darling.
Anyone for more vegetables
This is why I think me and Alice broke up in the end-- Alice?
What are you bringing her in for?-- I could open a bottle of wine if you prefer
If I just had that confidence... -- Confidence?
What's that got to do with anything? -- Would you like some more ice cream? -- I've started to see a therapist
Why not a magician next? -- God mum, it's not the Middle Ages. It's a normal thing to do
It's just good to have someone to actually talk to about how are you feeling you charge him?
Have you been fishing anymore this month, Ian? -- No, I don't mean that
hmm
Your Aunt Sarah was here the other night, her eldest just got into University
I'm not saying these things to be mean. Well, maybe you should think about it before opening your mouth
I just think it's good to have a
some like constructive non blaming conversation about the way you feeling
Listen, I forgot to tell ya
Now put plenty of vegetables in here --  Yup -- Man, make sure you eat them you'll get a bit slim
I will do -- You getting enough?
Yes, yes
Hey man
Yeah, yeah it was okay sort of
Yeah, we talked but we just didn't really talk about that kind of stuff, like I
Just feel it's probably not conversation I'm gonna have with my parents
Yeah, probably better if it's just me and you and therapist and you know that
Mm-hmm did get some pretty good chicken though
very tender
The dark truths in our book things you should never tell children may not be suitable for children
But the book can offer solace humor and relief to the older ones among us. Click the link to learn more